they reject nation how you do and it's
Greg Alba here tunneled we're gonna
watch the trailer for 1989's Pet
Sematary today Fred Gwynne I don't
really remember the original I never
read the book remember something about a
cat dying jack comes back then a kid
dies and doesn't come back right or I
believe flash and friends resurrect
Superman
yeah they turn the earth backwards and
then you know he comes back to life it's
great well hey I was doing the Justice
League oh sorry
I sure remember the Justice League oh
[Music]
yes and that totally incorrect I know we
could have had a good bit going and you
ruined oh yeah those those references
are really what stood out to me from
justice it was the funniest moment in
the movie ruin the joke let's watch this
just like a pit I did remember that one
I do chase Jason Cloris in every horror
revitalization Wow I even got into
throwing a whole flourish there's a new
backyard job scares
[Music]
okay yes yes dare each other go into the
woods at night it comes at night
[Music]
interesting let's get out they don't
beer
[Music]
or maybe does some crazy folktale or
something I don't know it was
[Music]
[Music]
sometimes dead is better hey samba Terry
[Music]
if you were to say we're remaking Pet
Sematary for the modern day this is a
thousand percent what I would expect
maybe because I want to sound like an
intellectual film nerd the parts I was
most drawn to in the trailer the very
beginning look very cliche but then but
then when they start doing then oh yeah
the little drum and stuff yeah and then
they were kind of doing this quiet place
looking vibe yeah my pictures had a big
hit off that yeah yeah and here looking
at the woods and everything like that
mood and atmosphere that was really
appealing to me that was like oh this is
a little bit different and then it
turned into I was Pet Sematary the set
up Pet Sematary is pretty simple to wrap
your head around you know you bury
things in the on holy ground and they
come back wrong like Superman like
Superman he's spun around the earth I
you know I just I tried and I failed
forget that joke Cemetery I like the
vibe of this trailer I like horror stuff
that takes place like in the countryside
when it's not just like oh we live in a
haunted house when there's like a little
bit more to what makes it freaky yeah
and I like these like kids and masks and
stuff I feel like that's a kind of a
neat way to expound upon this it kind of
looks like a cult ish vibe that are
going on I think this is the two dudes
this is a Kevin Cole sure Dennis
wittmeyer who made starry eyes so I
gotta imagine that there will be a fair
amount of intensity to the overall punch
and tone of this yeah I mean even though
it looks like Pet Sematary the remake
for the 2010 yeah it still looks like it
could definitely be very effective
looks like it was mood and tone I feel
like Jason Clark
a good horror movie for the amount of
appearances he makes and so many you
know lifts go always a delight John
let's go is terrific he constantly shows
up in things or I expect him to be in
something a lot more campy but then it
ends up not being campy he's good at
taking that kind of stuff seriously yeah
you know and he looks good with a big
old beard on too if you got to replace
Fred Gwynne alright you know I feel like
John Lithgow is not a bad choice I just
hope this film has some life about it
you know like it's it's the first
trailer so they're gonna try to sell you
on the mood and the horror this stuff
that makes it Pet Sematary and not even
the fact that the first Pet Sematary
who's necessarily a great film yeah I
mean I always regard that as one of like
the middle area Stephen King adaptations
lovely a memorable cheesy film yeah yeah
there's some cool stuff about it but
it's not aged incredibly not I
especially think what makes the stories
like this very effective is if the
characters and the family have like real
personality rather than just a lot of
staring and a lot of you who didn't link
like always a setup up this is a
horrible this is a horror movie like
even just their family scene for movies
like this story i got think of the
conjuring movies those films work so
well because the families have such a
life about them that when scary stuff
it's not happening it doesn't feel like
a horror movie the way this movie is lit
and shot makes it seem like it's always
gonna be a horror movie yeah dark and
dour the whole time and the kids are all
gonna know like right up front this is
bad yeah that's something I definitely
would want as a strong family dynamic
especially because you do get those
iconic scenes at least with I don't know
if they're gonna twist it but at least
with the little boy coming back and like
that's pretty wrenching maybe it'll be
the little girl this time could be I
mean it certainly seems like they're
pitching her as a focal character I mean
they have like the first few shots of
the trailer early yeah are you excited
yeah this all ours well I get the
impression that because it was such a
successful remake we're just gonna do
all the Stephen King's yeah all the
Stephen King ones that people were not
fully satisfied with and now
we make them for the modern-day time yes
satisfy us it's get a third shining one
that both the audience and Stephen King
can agree upon the late Stanley Kubrick
also all the wood stuff does look cool I
think there's a lot of cool as much as
men jokes as we're cracking here I mean
yes it's got a lot of it's cliche stuff
you know bloody fingerprints on stuff
screechy sound yes the part that looked
most appealing to me is when the trailer
was slowing down and taking its time
because that level of mood can really
get underneath someone's skin and I
think for Pet Sematary to be effective
you got you got to do that and I don't
know if this is more closely linked to
the actual source material or not I have
no idea it's something strikes me in
terms of the direction of like the first
ones pretty cheesy so we got to make
something super serious like go the
complete opposite route I don't think
that's necessarily true I mean part of
what makes it so effective is the fact
that when you're hanging out with the
kids we stand by Mears yeah it might
seem like a weird point to harp on but I
think it's a very important point to
make sure that when it's not horror you
don't treat it like you're in a horror
movie yeah I wanted to be just a family
who's been on this movie yeah who's you
know going through this experience
together and that is one thing I
definitely hope that they they at least
build out but even everyone is is look
out Judd name
yeah the Fred Gwynne Carey yeah I god
yes yeah the Franklin was like you're up
buried your cat for a reason yeah
suspicious over-the-top kind of
character yeah and then you got John
Lithgow who looks like traumatized and
serious you know that's a very different
take which you know a man who's been
living alone in the woods which is like
cool to do like if you're gonna do a
remake do the opposite to give a
different execution yeah give it a
different flavor guess one thing that
this made me wonder about was you know I
feel like one of the freakier elements
of the original movie is Zelda you know
they come in on her in the bed and she's
all like withered and weird we didn't
really get a sense for that in this
trailer so I wonder if maybe they're
gonna do something different about that
or if maybe I'm like a trailer number
two
we'll get an actual glimpse at that but
no no you know well hey before we wrap
this up I wanted to give a page from the
day shout-out to a man who is in love
with horror and that's a guy named Scuba
Steve boobs guys go check out this guy's
Instagram he does a lot of illegal
graffiti work art find him arrest him as
soon as you can man needs to be stopped
but set him up in the way where even
while he's in prison he can still remain
pledge of the patron don't want him to
get access to any of the exclusive
videos over there yeah but still want
his pledge to go through mine every
month that's all I really care about
but Scuba Steve I know Halloween time is
one of your ultimate times you have a
tradition your listen off many of films
that you like to watch this time of year
I hope you get that tradition going it's
a good time to do online dating and
divide a girl over to your place she
gets scared grabs on to your chest
maybe digs her nails deep into your
chest then you cry you yell at her and
then it's over because that's the way
you operate you need to get your [ __ ]
together it's a good day anyway you can
graffiti her hey guys you can subscribe
to the reject nation you can click that
notification bell cuz youtubers always
say that and you can check us on patreon
over there we have TV show reactions as
well as weekly q and A's I don't know
why I'm talking with such a serious face
bye bye